en las elecciones legislativas del
domingo en colombia los 16
representantes para víctimas serán una
de las novedades y fueron ilusionantes
en su concepción es la oportunidad para
que las víctimas las dos de las víctimas
comience a entablar un diálogo
equitativo a la par con el resto de
representantes políticos de nuestro país
las curules como se las conoce en
colombia son fruto de los acuerdos de
paz de 2016 entre la extinta guerrilla
de las farc y el estado y aunque fueron
rechazadas por el congreso la corte
constitucional la revivió en 2021 las 16
circunscripciones representan a las
zonas más afectadas por el conflicto
para un total de 167 municipios sin
embargo denuncian que la mayoría de
curules no habrían quedado en manos de
las verdaderas víctimas yo sí creo que
una revictimización en algunos lugares
que puso en alto riesgo a varios de los
candidatos y a varios de los aspirantes
precisamente porque competían en un
escenario muy desigual entre los
elegidos hay representantes cercanos a
partidos políticos con financiación
dudosa e incluso cercanos al
paramilitarismo el caso que ha traído
más atención es el de yoyo tovar será
representante por la circunscripción 12
cesar guajira magdalena su padre es
jorge 40 un líder paramilitar de la zona
relacionado con cientos de asesinatos en
campaña france24 estuvo con melva mieles
sus rivales según la confesión de otro
paramilitar sus padres fueron asesinados
por jorge 40 ahora se siente
revictimizada
[Música]
de las 16 sólo han quedado tres mujeres
mientras que muchas de las víctimas
participantes en los comicios se han
quejado del abandono del estado por
ejemplo no recibieron la financiación
prometida para la campaña otras que
prefieren no hablar públicamente sienten
que es ahora después de las elecciones
cuando su vida vuelve a estar en peligro